here's something that i just found out
existed
um proving the old adage that ignorance
is bliss
erotic weight gaining is a thing
unfortunately the new york post reports
on the important story of a guy named
brian nicknamed
gaynor bull who has intentionally gained
over 300 pound
pounds he eats 10 000 calories a day one
meal for him is like three combo meals
five or six sides now has a stomach the
size of a small asteroid and
again all of this is on purpose uh some
kind of like fetish
and he apparently has legions of fans
who watch him eat
and just enjoy gazing upon his bulbous
physique uh one fan on instagram for
example left a comment saying
you are one perfect inflating huge
handsome bear
by the way the words inflating and
handsome
really don't go together but but
here's my point um do i have a point
i i think i do the point is that the
internet should be destroyed uh it is a
cancer it is a virus
um and this is this is part of the
problem this guy
brian clearly mentally ill his fans
clearly mentally ill and mentally ill
people have always existed
presumably fat fetishists have always
existed in some capacity
but now with the internet people like
this are are able to congregate they're
able to form
communities where they encourage each
other in their perversion and their
degeneracy
and that's maybe the worst thing about
the internet there's a lot of
competition for that title but
perhaps the worst thing is what it has
done to the concept of
community because it used to be that
your community
was the neighborhood where you live uh
or or you form a community
as a church or around some other sort of
solid healthy thing real world
thing now a community just becomes a
collection of people who enjoy
the same thing and often the thing they
enjoy is repulsive and self-destructive
and bizarre
so there's no edification there's no
growth
well there is growth just not not
emotional and spiritual growth uh is
what i'm talking about
there's nothing nothing positive to come
of of the community other than this
mutual encouragement
to continue being weirdos and that's
most of the community on the internet
that's really what it is
just a bunch of weirdos getting together
and encouraging each other and telling
each other that they're not really
weirdos
um you know it's it's someone has some
some freaky gross thing they're into
they can just google it
and boom they find a whole collection of
other lunatics just like them
whereas in the past before the internet
you know they would have hidden that
part of themselves
in shame as they should maybe seek
counseling for it either of those
options are
better than what we have now um and
because now you can
you can you know it's certainly
preferable to or preferable to going on
instagram and getting your kicks by
watching a morbidly obese man eat a
burrito which is what's
where we are now and and by the way this
cheapening of the idea of community
it doesn't just apply to this fetish
type type of stuff
i mean i think it applies even to you
know people that say they're in a
community because they all like the
movie star wars or something like that
um or you know communities of people
that play video games
there's nothing wrong with playing video
games or liking star wars that's not
really a community though that's just
you enjoy the same thing great that
shouldn't be a community because there's
no other there's no shared value system
there
the only shared experience is just this
recreational thing you like doing
uh it's not really what a community is
supposed to be
and we we as humans do
need community but we're finding
we are we are fulfilling that need
in these kinds of communities around
some one little
thing that we like even if it's a
perfectly fine thing
rather than fulfilling that need through
a real
real life um
you know community hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated